Greek police have been accused of
beating up migrants and illegally
deporting them back to Turkey reports
that Greek security forces physically
assaulted migrants emerged earlier this
year when thousands gathered in border
areas after turkey encouraged them to
leave to Europe but now DW and other
investigative reporters have been able
to confirm some sort stories of abuse
and illegal deportations after tracking
down victims in Turkey they allege Greek
police arrested them without a warrant
and forced them onto boats back to
Turkey
now Florian Schmitz is one of the
co-authors of that report and joins us
now from the Greek city of Thessaloniki
Florian what have you been hearing from
the migrants who say they've been beaten
by Greek police together with our
partners like us reports delicate and
the Dutch newspaper fell we were able to
locate migrants in Turkey who basically
told us that they were arrested by Greek
police under false pretenses saying that
they would be issued new papers and then
they were taken in almost all of them
say that the police confiscated their
phones and other personal belongings
some told us that there was violence
involved and then they say that they
were brought in a vent to the Everest
the river between Turkey and Greece
where they were put on dinghies and
pushed back to the Turkish side but at
the end of March our Turkey
correspondent Julia Hahn interviewed
refugees at the Turkish border Don of a
journey and found people with some
similar stories
that's just briefly listening we're from
Afghanistan and we've been working here
in Turkey for three to four years our
situation is very bad here we crossed
into Greece in order to go to Europe we
waited for three to four days at the
border and then we headed to
Thessalonica there the Greek police beat
us and sent us back here the Greek
police took off all our clothes last
night we only had boxer shorts again and
again
I'm telling you they told us to lay down
like that when we did they beat and then
they hit us again floor and those are
pretty strong accusations has there been
any official response from the Greek
government we did get a response the
government of course denies everything
they call the allegations regarding
human rights violations by Greek law
enforcement personnel fabricated and
false interestingly though they also say
that the measures taken so far have been
proportionate to the gravity of the
situation Greek media speak of a new
agenda of aggressive surveillance the
Conservative government here is under a
lot of pressure to manage the migrant
situation in Greece
many Greeks feel like the country is
doing the dirty work for Europe
maintaining the infamous hot spots on
the islands and thus support the
government even with such drastic
measures like push backs would also be
wrong to scapegoat Greece in the
situation since Brussels has not managed
to come up with a sustainable solution
for the migrant situation a Florida and
Ebola situation was difficult enough
before the coronavirus what impact has
the pandemic had on the situation there
the question is much rather how does
Corona affect the situation within the
country the border between between
Greece and Turkey is officially closed
all official deportation procedures are
on hold at the same time the corona
lockdown and the strict measures imposed
by the state of Greece made it a lot
easier for the police to extend into the
mainland and arrest migrants in refugee
camps and in the cities so according to
the people we talked to the corona
lockdown initiated
a new strategy of push backs from Greece
to Turkey Florent remains one of the
authors of this research thank you and
you can find the full report on our
website that's of course DW com